I'm just curious what were some common
cliches at that time you were seeing in
these scripts well some big mistakes I
would say that I would get in scripts
coming in the door were like big really
big dense blocks of description just too
many words on the page the worst is when
they make the margins really small so
that they can fit more on the page
because they haven't really tightened
the script up enough so with making the
margins tiny and and even the spacing
like the letting you can make tighter
and final draft and in other
screenwriting software's if you do that
the reader immediately knows that you're
cheating and they know that even your
script may say it's a hundred and ten
pages but if you went to normal margins
and normal spacing it would probably be
like 123 or something so readers hate
that you know right off the bat because
you're taking up more of their time and
it also shows that you're an
undisciplined writer who doesn't know
how to write a well paced script in the
proper spacing and format that fits into
the average script being let's say 105
210 pages these days so there's that and
then there is takes too long to get to
the inciting incident the inciting
incident should be between page 8 to 10
sometimes 12 is okay but we really need
a catalyst you know we need an inciting
incident to happen and then as well
later on you don't want act 1 to be too
far into the script it should be the the
break of act 1 and act 2 should be
probably around page 30 it doesn't have
to be exactly on page 30 but around page
30 but some being inner scripts it
literally be like page 47 before a
really big turn and direction happened
and it felt like we were in act 2 so
those are some examples but the
on-the-nose dialogue could be one of the
worst I like to say sometimes that
Talking Heads dialogue where it's just
two characters talking to each other
kind of at each other and then Q&A
sessions or the
and that's where one character keeps
asking another questions and then they
just keep answering it so it's almost
like an interview and if that goes on
for too long it really tires out the
reader and it just gets really what we
call on the nose
you